[Música]
y tal y como están buenas tardes
he escuchado
no saben qué gusto y qué emoción el
estar de frente a ustedes y me den la
oportunidad de compartir un poco de la
historia de mi vida
tuve la fortuna
como muchos y tantas mujeres de tabasco
de crecer en torno a canales kaká o
tales animales de traspatio hortalizas y
al final un fogón humeando de donde
nacían platillos maravillosos
emblemáticos de nuestra cocina
tradicional y que no sólo se alimentaba
en el cuerpo sino terminaron enamorando
mi alma
tuve la fortuna como muchos
y tantas familias de tabasco
de nacer
en el seno de una familia
sencilla modesta
con grandes valores y principios
respetuosa de sus tradiciones y
orgullosa de sus raíces
son ellos mi familia los pilares que le
dieron identidad y sentido a mi vida son
ellos los que forjaron a la cocinera
tradicional que soy hoy y a la mujer
de mi abuelo materno aprendí entre
tantas cosas que el chocolate se bebe ni
muy frío
y muy caliente
y muy espeso ni muy aguada ni muy dulce
ni muy amargo
me enseñó que la tierra se cultiva con
respeto y con amor
y que ella la naturaleza te lo regresa
agradecida en abundantes en abundantes
cosechas
me enseñó
lo sublime que puede ser el sabor de la
carne del armadillo del pp escuincle y
del venado
pero también me enseñó que las mujeres y
los hombres de buena lid respetan sus
tiempos de reproducción y sus crías
porque ellas serán las que nos alimenten
mañana y a las nuevas generaciones
me enseñó
y es una religión para mí
ir muy temprano muy temprano al mercado
antes de que salgan los primeros rayos
de luz porque sólo de esa forma vas a
llenar tus pulmones de olor a campo
fresco y vas a poder encontrar las
primeras yucas que todavía vuelan a
tierra mojada
de mi madre aprendí que las mujeres de
esta tierra nacidas en tabasco son de un
espíritu inquebrantable que a pesar de
las adversidades o las circunstancias de
la vida se ponen de pie
se levantan y luchan cada día por forjar
hombres hijos
responsables productivos honestos pero
sobre todo comprometidos
con su gente y con su tierra
de mi abuela paterna aprendí
las pocas veces que tuve la oportunidad
de disfrutar de su compañía que no hay
nada mejor para curar el alma que un
buen caldo de gallina y
de mi hermana
mi compañera de muchas aventuras
entrecanales y cacaotales aprendí
que no importa quién tenga la culpa
las dos nos llevamos el castigo
todos estos personajes
fueron los pilares
que forjaron a la mujer ya la cocinera
hace 4 años
soy abogada de profesión
no soy no hace cuatro años se aboga de
persona
me salte lo de la profesión
soy abogada de profesión
ingresada en la universidad juárez
pero soy cocinera tradicional por
vocación y por pasión
hace 4 años tomé la decisión
de abandonar el ejercicio de la
profesión para dedicarme a lo que
realmente me apasiona que es cocinar
cocinar con leña y cocinar con uva y
dejé tantito a un ladito la toga y el
birrete por si no me sale bien esto pues
me regreso
y señores me vestí
del traje tradicional de tabasco para
hacerle honor a las mujeres artesanas de
mi pueblo
e inicie el proyecto más importante de
mi vida y que en el que yo creo me voy a
morir
inicia la restauración de una pequeña
casa chontal en el ejido buenavista en
comalcalco tabasco una casa maravillosa
que me llevo año y medio restaurarla
y colocar en ellas elementos
con los que las familias modestas de
tabasco vivían y convivían
tiene tejas de barro antiguas rescatadas
de una ex hacienda cacaotera extinta
piso de ladrillo adoquinado
una vieja máquina de coser porque quiero
evocar recordar y mantener vivo a las
señoras después de su larga jornada
cosiendo y confeccionando sus propios
trajes
un viejo mortero porque había que pilar
el café de la cosecha resguardarlo muy
bien para luego tomarse un buen café
colado en manga de manta y un metate
para moler un buen chocolate
entre muchas otras cosas más la
recreación de cocina chontal
es tan perfecta
que transporta en el tiempo 50 70 años
atrás y saben cuál es la razón el
tabasqueño
mi intención fue
rescatar al tabasqueño
transportarlo en el tiempo 50-60 años
atrás
y que traigan de nuevamente que traiga
de nuevo a su mente y a su corazón
aromas y sabores
en las mesas de las casas de nosotros
todos los tabasqueños
ya no podemos encontrar un buen horneado
un chirmol una carne picadita con arroz
y eso es verdaderamente triste
quiero que todos nosotros los
tabasqueños nos demos la oportunidad de
estar en ese lugar de recargar nos las
pilas y de darnos cuenta que es momento
de reivindicar el orgullo
de pertenecer a una tierra prodigiosa
de hombres y mujeres que con sus manos
han mantenido viva nuestra historia
nuestro compromiso es
que cada uno de nosotros nos fijamos en
esos grandes personajes
y transmitamos todo nuestro legado a las
nuevas generaciones solo
y solo así
podremos nosotros decir
que tenemos un corazón un corazón
palpitando
y que quien lo bombea es nuestra
identidad nuestro orgullo por nuestras
raíces y el respeto a nuestras
tradiciones
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]